according to the dominant scientific
hypothesis today
around 13.8 billion years ago there
occurred to the tremendous event dubbed
the big bang which created our universe
it is likely that incredibly powerful
gravity waves compressed primary gas
into gigantic clumps while unrelenting
gravity forces ignited thermonuclear
fire in their depths thus lighting the
universe with the first stars
these forces also grouped the stars into
large scale clusters which were later to
unite into yet more complex structures
of colossal proportions
billions of years later one of them
became the cradle of an amazing
phenomenon
life
and even though mankind is still
confined to our native system we have
found out a lot about our own galaxy
what is it that we already know about
the milky way
[Music]
long before telescopes had been invented
people could observe a light strip
crossing the heavens
the fascinating and mysterious
phenomenon prompted a multitude of
legends
but it took thousands of years of
scientific progress to finally account
for it
it turned out that the milky way wasn't
a path of gods
what it is is the dissipated light of
billions of stars too remote to
distinguish each one separately
the idea of the stars around us making
our part of a single structure of
enormous dimensions was first suggested
by emanuel kant back in 1755.
he also assumed that some nebulae
discovered by scientists could in fact
be remote star clusters that is other
galaxies
this ingenious gas was well ahead of its
time with the philosopher's
contemporaries initially dismissing it
only in the early 20th century do the
progress of observation equipment enable
scientists to confirm the existence of
other galaxies
and in 1936 edwin hubble devised the
classification system
many of its principles are still
referred to by scientists today
according to the system the milky way
falls into the category of barred spiral
galaxies
although it took a long while before it
had assumed this today's looks
our galaxy is quite an old one since the
stars in its central globular clusters
were born as far back as around 13
billion years ago
at the same time there are some areas in
the milky way where stars are actively
born which means that there is always a
fresh supply of young stars
the collected data points to the fact
that the milky way is a comparatively
large galaxy in astronomical terms the
diameter of its disk measures as much as
two hundred 000 light years with a halo
reaching out into space much deeper yet
our galaxy is home to at least 200
billion various stars as well as 25 to
100 billion brown dwarfs
in addition it contains over a trillion
planets
countless small celestial objects as
well as clouds of cosmic dust and
interstellar gas which may reach
gigantic dimensions
at the same time regular mata accounts
for a small ratio in the galaxy
around 90 percent of the milky way's
overall mass is the so-called dark
matter
the amount of light emitted by this
mysterious and widespread substance is
negligible however dark matter plays an
active role in gravitational interaction
even though most of the galactic mass
remains invisible we can still calculate
it
to that end scientists refer to star's
trajectories of movement around the
center of the milky way
according to the estimates the overall
mass of our galaxy reaches 0.8 to 1.5
trillion solar masses
the structure of the milky way is quite
elaborate
we'll start our journey today from its
center
this area of the galaxy is shrouded in
massive clouds of gas and dust
but by a happy chance we can observe it
through the so-called bardes window
an area of space with lower amounts of
dust
just like most spiral galaxies
the milky way has a supermassive black
hole in its center which is surrounded
with an accretion disk with a radius
roughly three light years
dubbed sagittarius star it is the
closest object of this class to us
its mass is 4.3 million solar masses and
its radius isn't over 16 million
kilometers
which is three times smaller than
mercury's orbit
the first data about the nature of the
object in the center of our galaxy was
acquired in the course of long
observations and thorough calculations
only as recently as on may 12 2022 was
it possible to get the first image with
the help of the eht network of radio
telescopes and so the earlier hypotheses
were confirmed
the area in the center of our galaxy is
highly populated
more than 6 000 stars have already been
detected within three light-years from
the black hole with the orbits of some
of them defined rather accurately
for example there is a white blue star
designation s62 which is 17.8
astronomical units away from the black
hole on its closest approach to it
while moving at 6.7 percent the speed of
light
classical mechanics laws are inadequate
for description of the trajectory of
movement of a star as swift as that
because of relativistic effects
just to illustrate the axis of its orbit
shifts by 75 angular minutes with every
completed orbit besides when crossing
this area in space we can see several
large star clusters with a total mass of
around 1 million solar masses
and slightly further roughly 200 light
years away
another massive black hole is likely to
be lurking whose mass should be around a
hundred thousand times that of the sun
traveling further on we will reach the
central molecular cloud in a regularly
shaped area measuring sixteen hundred to
nineteen hundred light years whose mass
is over sixty million solar masses
there are great many stellar nurseries
and gas nebulae as well as protostars
and remnants of supernovae
most of the clouds mata is dense
hydrogen whose temperature fluctuates
between 50 and 600 kelvin which
corresponds to
223 degrees celsius below zero to
327 degrees celsius above zero spectral
analysis shows the gigantic nebula to
contain carbon monoxide methyl alcohol
and hydrocyanic acid in addition to
hydrogen
having receded from the milky way's
center a bit we will see that it is
encompassed by a bulge a bright and
massive formation of an elliptical shape
with its length reaching 10 000 light
years
its transverse diameter is roughly 7
light years
the total mass of the bulge is as much
as 10 billion times that of the sun
the exact number of the stars cannot be
calculated because their radiation
blends and renders any estimates
unrealistic
being elongated the bulge forms the
so-called bar stretching for
approximately 13 000 light years and
serving as the base for spiral galactic
arms
it is here at one of its ends that we
can see the star cluster stevenson ii
containing the largest known star today
its designation is stevenson 2-18 and
its radius is
2150 times that of the sun
unfortunately chances of finding
exoplanets orbiting this outstanding
object are quite minuscule even if
planets did exist at some point in the
past the hypergiant would have swallowed
them up while it was expanding
the galaxy's center is home to billions
of stars and apparently a great number
of exoplanets
chances of encountering a potentially
habitable world among this great
multitude are much lower than in less
populated areas of the galaxy
this is due to the fact that when a big
number of stars are located close
together they destabilize exoplanets
orbits while their powerful radiation is
lethal to all living things
that is why a special area in the galaxy
is defined as the habitable zone it
looks like a ring with a radius
measuring 22 to 29 000 light years and
contains star systems with the most
favorable conditions for the genesis of
biological life
worlds encompassed by the ring languish
in exposure to excessive radiation while
beyond the ring there's a lack of heavy
elements
however mathematical modelling shows
that stars within galaxies are able to
migrate thousands of light years away
thus either leaving the habitable zone
or entering it
consequently with an exoplanet lying
within the zone it does not
automatically suggest favorable
conditions on it
moving on away from the center of the
milky way we will have a chance to check
out its most impressive part
the galactic disk
it is made up of two components with
different properties
the first one known as the thin disc
measures one thousand to one thousand
three hundred light years in thickness
and its visible radius measures as much
as fifty thousand light years
on the edge it gradually dissipates with
the outermost stars lying up to a
hundred thousand light years away from
the galaxy's center
this part of the milky way contains
around 80 percent of the galaxy's
visible mass and in fact it was the last
component to have formed
as for the thick disc its diameter is
comparable to that of the thin disc but
it's four times a stick and is much more
rarefied
it is made up of old stars and is
practically devoid of interstellar gas
observations of some stars in the milky
way as well as mathematical modelling
show our galaxy to have swallowed up
another one in the period from 11 to 8
billion years ago
this hypothetical cosmic structure was
dubbed gaia enceladus
it is thought that it contributed
several billion stars to the milky way
as well as great amounts of interstellar
gas and dark matter
it is thanks to this tremendous event
that most of our galaxies thick disk
formed and an additional supply of gas
led to a stellar baby boom
there is no doubt that spiral arms are
the most noticeable structural elements
of our galaxy's disk
usually two major ones are singled out
the scutum centaurus arm and the perseus
arm and two minor ones the norma arm and
the carina sagittarius arm
sometimes a fifth large arm is taken
into account named after the cygnus
constellation
galactic arms are areas of especially
high star count
most of interstellar gas is also
concentrated here which is why the rate
of star formation in the arms is three
to five times higher than in the galaxy
on average
they spend the first millions of their
lives in open clusters
but gravity forces are too weak to hold
the stars close together for a long time
this destabilizes the clusters and young
stars gradually drift away from each
other
traveling along the carina sagittarius
arm we will reach a fork that links it
to the perseus arm
the length of this stellar structure
reaches 11 000 light years
and its width measures roughly 3
500 light years
it is referred to as the orion arm and
it is here
27 000 light years away from the
galaxy's center that the solar system is
located
from our planet's perspective the
galaxy's center is seen as a dark abyss
this is the grey drift an area of space
that shuts out the greater part of the
milky way from our gaze
it is filled with massive clouds of
interstellar gas and dust and its total
mass is as much as a million times that
to the sun
even though the great drift is
practically not transparent in the
optical range
its matter actively emits radio waves
and thermal energy
spectral analysis data reveals that the
clouds are mostly made up of hydrogen
with a small percentage of more complex
compounds
ammonia
alcohols and amino acids
the great drift is thought to be a
potential stellar nursery but it is
going to take a while until the first
stars light up in that area
while it is still not quite active let's
move on beyond the galaxy disk
even though its bright and clearly
defined arms attract a lot of attention
there is more to the milky way than that
if we look closer we will see the
vastest and the most terrified of its
components
the halo
its visible part spherical in shape
stretches for up to 260 thousand light
years away from the galaxy's center but
accounts for just a few percent of the
total mass
the halo contains a great number of
globular clusters made up of remarkably
old stars over 12 billion years of age
and several tremendous stellar streams
the sagittarius stream for example
made up of several thousand stars
encompasses our galaxy in an elongated
ellipses which is almost perpendicular
to the main plane
modelling shows that all these stars are
highly likely to have been
gravitationally captured by the milky
way from a dwarf satellite galaxy
designation sagittarius deg
it lies 500 000 light years away from
the milky way's center and is going to
be swallowed up by it completely within
several billion years
another dwarf galaxy has already met a
similar fate
lying in the canis major constellation
it was almost destroyed by the milky way
which pulled out millions of its stars
by gravity forces
stretching for 200 000 light years and
mixing with other stars
this string of stars with a total mass
of roughly 100 million solar masses has
already wrapped around our galaxy three
times
apart from bright but rare stars and
clusters the halo contains great amounts
of gas whose temperature reaches
millions of kelvin
also great amounts of dark matter are
thought to be scattered in the vicinity
of the milky way forming the so-called
dark halo
stretching for up to 2 million light
years
it hardly emits any electromagnetic
radiation and can be detected only by
gravitational interaction
the dark halo remains an unsolved
mystery
yet it greatly contributes to the global
stability of our galaxy
the milky way is just one of the
countless structures of the universe
together with other galaxies it forms
the local group
which in its turn is part of the virgo
supercluster
galaxy clusters group into filaments
which form still larger scale structures
cosmic scales are so stupendous that
they can hardly be appreciated by the
human mind
still our knowledge about the universe
gets more and more accurate with every
passing day
and mysteries of the cosmos succumb to
the human tenacity one after another
this is the power of the human mind and
progress
and we are proud to be part of it
feel free to give us a like if you are
ready to conquer the mysteries of the
universe alongside cosmo
let's keep in touch
[Music]
you